- We've been told about
other ways of knowing,
other ways of doing maths, non race,
anti-racist science
all this sort of thing.
Yet we do not go to any
Aboriginal communities
for vaccines.
We go to no first peoples
for cancer treatment.
We go to them for no
mathematical scientific
or artistic discoveries.
We do not go to them to rediscover
other languages and other cultures,
partly, largely because such communities
seem to have had not much
interest in other cultures.
Unlike the Western mind,
they seem not to have
taken a great interest.
So, the not courteous
thing would be us saying,
we've been courteous
for an awfully long time
and we're gonna stop because it seems
not to be doing us much good.
(upbeat music)
- All right.
I'm Dave Rubin and we are
on location in my house
there's, I think that counts
as though on location,
I think it does, yeah there you go.
And I am with my friend
and multiple author,
you've written 800 books,
if I'm not mistaken.
But your new book, his
new book is right here.
It is 'The War on the West.'
Douglas Murray, how are you, my friend?
- Great, great to be with you again.
- 800, how many?
- No, I think this is number seven.
- Number seven.
- So it's a little overshooting by you.
- Number seven but my
team told me this morning,
that this officially today,
marks your ninth appearance
on the Ruben Report.
- Ninth?
- Yes.
- Wow.
- And there is some debate as to whether,
you have now tied Gad Saad,
for number two at nine.
- There's one little question related to,
if he's actually eight or nine depending
on which way you wanna
count, Jordan Peterson
is 10, but you are solidly second, so--
- And I was your, what? Second guest ever?
- Yeah, you were like my second
or third guest back in 2015.
We're still doing it.
However, my friend, there
is a war on the West.
- Yeah.
- This country is burning.
See how I did that with my book too?
Very, very clever.
- Very clever.
- So, lets understand with that, you know.
For all the years that
we've been talking about
all of this stuff that now is known
as Wokeism which you
write about obviously,
but all of the culture wars
and all of the things that are happening,
should we have been yelling louder say,
seven years ago, when
we all started talking
about this loose group of people
that were kind of signaling,
did we miss something and maybe should
have been screaming louder
or was it gonna happen no matter what?
- I think it was gonna
happen no matter what.
I learned from the years I
was writing about Islamism
that you can spend 23 hours a day
dealing with a subject,
but if you're dealing with fanatics,
they're spending 24 hours a day doing it.
You just can't win in a way,
against fanatics in the short term.
And what we've realized in recent years
is the, let's say the woke bandwagon,
these people are radicals.
They're extremists, they're fanatics.
They have an extraordinary set of claims,
and they have just managed to push them,
bulldoze them right into the
center of all of our lives.
And as that movement has sort of,
crept closer and closer to people,
people realized that there
were no effective barricades.
I mean, I say in, the book that,
there was a sort of, for instance,
there was a conservative
idea which was mistaken,
which many people, including myself,
I had in recent years,
which was for instance,
that things like the critical race theory,
the intersectionality all of this crap,
that it would stop at the borders
of the STEM subjects.
it would never take over engineering,
it would never get into medicine,
that was wrong.
- You mean, it would never tell us
that two plus two equals five?
- Exactly, you know.
There was an assumption that,
okay, they'll do this
with the liberal arts,
they'll do this with
political science and stuff,
but they won't do it with engineering.
And the joke is, was always,
well at some point, the
bridges have to stay up.
And then they said, no, it turns out,
- We'll see,
- It turns out they don't.
- Yeah.
- If the bridges come down now,
it'll be because we live
in a cisheteronormative,
patriarchal, racist society,
which has institutional racism,
which is why the bridge fell down.
So, it's just flooded across everywhere.
And there's always that question of,
whether you could have done more
or shouted more or whatever.
But I think that a lot of
people didn't realize the scope
of what was coming at us.
- You have a line that I've quoted
probably 50 times on Twitter
and 50 times on my show
and probably on other people's shows,
that I think perfectly
encapsulates what's going on here,
which is that one day,
you said this to me
probably five years ago,
one day the Barbarians will be at the gate
and we'll be debating what gender pronouns
to call them.
- Yeah.
- Does that really sum up almost exactly
where we are?
And that really sort of,
gets to the title of the book
that we really are at a
societal war right now.
And instead really focusing
on what's going on,
we are debating trans-swimmers.
- Yeah.
- And women with penises
and the rest of this stuff.
- Yes.
Yeah, no, I mean, it is deranging.
I wrote about what I
regard as being this sort,
of crowd derangement in my previous book
in the 'Madness of Crowds'.
I could see it already
that this was happening.
It was gonna worse and worse.
People were being in,
people were being demanded
to say things they knew not to be true.
And now it's got to a stage beyond that.
I always thought that thing with,
that I'd described in
the 'Madness of Crowds'
was a sort of step towards something.
That the, say the guy
with a penis is a girl,
or, you're bigot.
And I think I may even
have said it to you,
that it was almost like
it was preparing us
for something because I always maintained
at the time if you
assault the basic things
we know to be true,
like the fact that there
are boys and girls,
men and women,
that you're not assigned to sex at birth
as if it's a sort of lottery system,
which if you've got a particularly bigoted
delivery nurse,
she'll just kind of,
(laughing).
That's not how it works,
there are boys and girls and,
but if you persuade people
that that's not true,
you can do an awful lot afterwards
because you've made people doubt
the things they were
absolutely certain about,
you know the cry now it's like well,
how do you know? I mean,
you were biologist.
And as a fine British feminist
said to somebody the other day, said,
"Well, I'm not a vet either,
but I know what a dog is."
so--
- Yeah, exactly.
- But a lot of people have
been browbeaten and cut in.
And I think that what I'm
trying to describe here
is what I think is the next stage of this,
which is a war on the fundamentals
of everything in our society.
A war on our history, a war on our past,
a war on our foundations,
a war on our culture,
and a war on the people in the culture.
What I describe as a war on white people,
which is a phrase that
a lot of people will,
- Yeah.
- Sort of jump at,
- But there's no other
way to describe it now.
Lots of different bigotries
exist in the world,
but the only one that's
completely tolerated
and indeed encouraged
in 21st Century America,
is hatred of and diminishment
of people for being white.
We wouldn't tolerate it
with any other skin color.
We wouldn't tolerate
it if people said that
black people should be treated differently
because of their skin color.
Only white people is this
now permissible with.
And that's because white people
are the inheritors of the West.
They're portrayed as
the people of the West
who must therefore pay
for the sins of the West.
- it's funny I was watching
in the last couple weeks, a movie,
'There Will Be Blood'.
- Oh yeah.
- Did you happen to see
it, with Daniel Day Lewis?
About the gold rush?
Well, not the gold rush, the oil rush
and going West in the
1800s into the 1900s.
And it's,
it's a lot of White people
doing horrible jobs,
horrible jobs in the
coal mines and digging
and things collapsing
on them and people dying
and fires and all of these things.
And it was making me think,
boy, we talk about the
history of this country
as if these White people first off,
as if they built all of this stuff
in honor of whiteness,
- Sure.
- Which is completely
insane, completely insane
and not true even in aorta of a percent.
But also, that these people who happen
to be white who built stuff, often
was very dangerous and lots of men,
- Yes.
- Were dying in the process.
- Well, I mean, I give a number
of examples of this of,
there are two original sins of the West
that are seen now, slavery and empire.
Are both the portrayed as if nobody else
in the world did them.
- Yeah.
- Which is nonsense.
- There were no slaves
before America, right?
- I mean, almost if,
I reckon that not one
in a million Americans
knows the following fact,
that 11 to 12 million slaves
were probably brought across the Atlantic
from Africa during the slave trade,
the Trans-Atlantic slave trade.
About 18 million Africans
were similarly sold
by their neighbors and
others in the slave trade
that went east.
So, why do we not know about
the 18 million slaves that
went east from Africa?
Because there's no remnant of them,
because the Arabs castrated all the men.
As I said, there's one in a million
Americans know that context this
that slavery happened
everybody was involved
in it, it was a horrible thing then,
it's a horrible thing now and
it's still going on now.
I've met slaves, myself,
people who've born into slavery in Africa.
And I don't think anyone knows this.
And so everyone's got the context
all outta sorts and the
one of course is empire.
And again, these things are talked about
as if nobody else did this,
countries across the world tried to
form or did form empires.
If you're gonna get the sense of the
British Empire into context,
you've gotta understand that.
If you want to get the history
of the Trans-Atlantic
Slave Trade into context,
you've gotta understand
what else was going on.
And as you say, that crucial thing
that it's not like everybody in the
past in the West was
like living in Clover.
During the latter stage
of the slave trade,
the Trans-Atlantic Slave Trade,
the average life of a man working
in one of the mills,
in one of the towns in the North
of England was about 37.
- Wow.
- They lived into their late 30s.
People on slave plantations lived longer.
Now, I'm not saying that slave plantations
were good or anything like it.
Of course, not.
I'm just saying like,
can you honestly look
at this and think that those,
White, if we must say that,
men in the Northern English
mill towns were free?
Did they actually have any
or much agency in their lives?
Did they have control of their lives?
Were they privileged?
No, not at all.
And it's a grotesque thing of our time
that we've decided that
we've gotta pretend
that these people were wildly privileged
as well as bigoted.
- Privileged, bigoted and again,
that they did it in the name of whiteness
or of power when it was,
they were literally just trying to survive
and often had to leave families
to take the worst kind of jobs.
So, I kind of wanna go
through the chapters
of the book, 'cause one thing that you do
that I just think is so
great in all your books,
you do very few chapters,
which I always think is
just such a clean way
of writing.
So, you really only have four chapters
in this book and then you have some,
some sub chapters within that.
But before we get to that,
since we are at this
place where the war seems
to be here, are you
surprised at all that maybe,
not the punditry class that's been warning
about this, but just that
our institutions didn't
have better defenses?
Like even now, watching
the college's crumble,
like there's still no defense,
I remember a few years ago,
the University of Chicago put out
a defensive free speech and everyone said,
this is it this will be
the one that will defend.
And I remember saying, no,
this isn't gonna be it,
it'll be okay there
for a little bit maybe,
or the Harper's Letter
where people sign things
and everyone go, this is the one.
- Yeah yeah.
- And yet it has just marched and marched
and marched.
Are you surprised these institutions
or our political leaders or something,
didn't have something in the toolkit,
- Yeah.
- To deal with this better?
- I'm surprised at the
institutional failure.
- Yeah.
- I think there's a tendency we all have
that in whatever is the
thing we know about,
we think that it's going to go,
it may go wrong there,
but it won't go wrong in that discipline.
So, I had this.
I sort of thought,
well, as I said earlier,
surely the mathematicians
aren't gonna do this
other ways of knowing.
- Yeah.
- But here we are.
We've got equitable maths
being taught in the US.
I thought, surely you're not gonna get
in the medical fields.
But some of the race hucksters
that I write about in this book,
they flooded through the medical field.
I was speaking to a friend in
the medical profession the other day
and I was saying, I just can't believe.
He's like, "I thought medical journals,
"like there was no way they would start
"to get into stuff about,
problematizing whiteness,
yet, here we are".
- So, I guess my question really then,
is more about the political institutions
that it's not like we have well,
I was about to say,
it's not like we have
laws that punish people
based on the color of their skin,
but we kind of do.
And during COVID we were prioritizing,
- Yes.
- In certain places,
- COVID vaccines based
on the color of skin
and all that.
- Yes.
And other medical procedures.
- And other, right exactly.
We genuinely were.
Did something, we screw
up something politically
there too, I mean, or just our politicians
are usually just weak except for the
guy who happens to be running this state?
- Well,
I think that politicians see
a cost benefit analysis and
things, it turns out one
of the disappointments
in my life has been the,
I made the presumption of people
in politics are interested
in truth.
- Yeah, (laughs)
- That's not the case.
- You're not 22 anymore, are you Douglas?
- Its not the case.
They're interested in
achieving and retaining power,
and there are some good
people in politics,
I'm not saying that all of
them are guilty of this.
But you get this cost benefit analysis so,
is there a benefit to saying
something that everyone
knows to be true if the
cost of it is a small,
but very dedicated number of
people who are determined to
destroy you.
Generally speaking that
chases people away,
and by the way,
that's the history of fanaticism across
the hearers, small but
very dedicated groups
of fanatics can do an outsized
amount of damage by just
running straight at things.
- Right, the original social media my bad,
I suppose.
- Yeah, and I think
politicians among others
are highly susceptible to that.
They dip a toe in the water and they just,
have I had no idea it was as bad as that.
And they don't tread on it again,
newspaper editors and others are similar,
a lot of big media companies,
they don't wanna touch that,
that subject's electric don't do that.
So, I mean, I'm disappointed,
but I'm not surprised.
- All right. So let's
start at the beginning.
chapter one is about race
and we've already touched on
some of the race stuff,
I guess when now you think about it,
and when I was reading it,
it's we almost solved the
race thing in America.
We were pretty damn close, you
allude to that in the book,
- Yeah.
- Like we really were pretty damn close
and now it does seem worse,
maybe not in my day to day life,
but at the media level, the societal level
- Yes.
- Does seem worse, what a sad statement.
- It's, partly, I believe
a misapprehension caused
by a misrepresentation
of the society.
So obviously I may have
to get straight into it.
The race chapter, the
death of George Floyd,
the summer of George Floyd riots.
The, if you look at the,
I mean, we were all,
it's always worth reminding ourselves in,
in most countries at that point,
we were made to seclude ourselves
in the months before that happened,
people were literally isolated
and told by government to isolate.
And one of the things that did to us,
I believe is that it took
away our societal antenna.
If we meet people, if we meet strangers,
friends and everything, we
sit around a dinner table,
stand a bar,
you try things out and you row
about things and you discuss
things and you josh about things,
and much more if you remove all of that
and then something terrible happens,
and a group of very dedicated people say
that shows X is the case.
Then people start to think,
maybe that is the case.
Now I was in Britain when George Floyd
was killed.
But I had a moment I've known this,
I've known America all my life.
And I had a slight double take moment,
like I'm,
I don't think you can just
kill Black people in America,
I'm fairly sure you can't.
I know you can't, but he
were these protests saying,
we've got to stop the fact
that Black people walking the
streets from American can at
any point be killed by a car.
And that's not true.
- Yeah.
- But there was a moment of doubt,
which is one of the
reasons why police forces
in among all things countries
at my own country birth
in Britain really didn't
know what to do at the
beginning of the protests.
And some policemen were persuaded
to take the knee to protesters
because they panicked.
They thought maybe this representation
that we've being shown is true.
If you look at the opinion
data that we have on how many
Black people, Americans
believe are killed every year,
unarmed by armed American police officers,
the figures are out by
several orders of magnitude.
I've got the percentages in there,
among people who describe
themselves as very liberal,
significant proportion of them,
think that more than 10,000
Black men are killed every year
by American police, when
those men are unarmed.
- It it's some, real number I don't,
yeah I'm not gonna--
- It's somewhere around 10.
- Yeah, it's about a dozen, yeah.
- Which is actually less than
the number of policemen killed
by armed Black men so there's a
another debate there.
- Yeah.
- But yes, I mean,
so it's off by several orders
of magnitude people who
have describe themselves as liberal.
Think that it's somewhere
between 1000 and 10,000.
So you're dealing with a
completely grotesque distorted
picture of the present that
people in America and then
around the world have been
persuaded to fall for,
and that has consequences
because if you are told that this
is the case and that you live
in a society that's racist,
then you bring up White people
to believe that they are
somehow contaminated from birth.
You bring up young Black kids
to believe that they are able
to be hunted down and killed
in America by the state.
You massively exacerbate
all racial differences.
But what this has fallen
into has been this,
not just what I described
as war on White people,
but this set of massive overreach claims
about what is underneath this,
well we've always been
like this, you know?
And so we have the
starting of the rewriting,
of our history in the name
of racial justice and social
justice, in America you
have a 1619 project,
no small thing it's the New
York Times that rolls that out,
led by non historian non-specialists
who make totally verifiably false claims
about the foundations of this country.
But you see the same thing
in the UK, in Canada,
a lot of people will have missed it,
but around the same time,
the last couple years there's
been this stampede in Canada
when there was some graves
that were found near
a church school.
And then it was claimed
that these were mass graves,
of indigenous children killed
by the Catholic church in massive numbers.
And churches were burnt
down across Canada,
including first nations churches,
not one body has been found,
not one excavation occurred.
They didn't even use ultrasound.
So we have been embedding
totally false claims about our
collective pasts in the names,
of trying to refine the present.
- What do you make of the
way it spreads that falsehood
and how it spreads?
So you go into the numbers
about what's going on with
policing in America, but there
were BLM riots in London,
as you mentioned,
that the way it now spreads through
the internet to then land on
the shores overseas for
a problem that nobody,
if you would've asked the average person,
I suspect if you asked the
average Black person in London
four years ago,
do you have a real problem
with policing here?
I'm gonna guess that the
average person would've said no,
maybe somebody had some marginal thing,
but what do you make
of that transfer thing?
- Oh yeah, I mean there was a,
a head of BLM movement in
Oxford called Sasha Johnson.
I'll be careful what I say about her,
because I believe she's
still at the hospital.
Sasha Johnson wrote a tweet as head of,
led some very unpleasant protests
said horrible things about White people
said on social media, she
wanted to make White people,
her slaves that that was the plan.
She said, she didn't want to equality,
she wanted revenge, by the way--
- It's nice when they're honest about it.
- She was completely
honest about it, I say,
I'm being careful about
because she's a mother
and she was at a house
party in London last year.
And she was shot in the head.
And immediately some politicians,
including the Black former
shadow home secretary said,
"It's appalling this poor young woman
"Is been gunned down for her beliefs."
She was gunned down by a
gang of Black young men
who were shooting at a
house party she was at.
So again,
we have these kind of just
totally false narratives,
you import the BLM thing to Oxford,
- Yeah.
- In England.
And then you have this horrible radical,
and then something terrible
happens then all of it,
all of it is spun through
the thing of white racism.
- Let's do a little sidebar for a moment,
'cause just as you spun
that story together
and all the lies and everything else
over the last couple years are you,
to me if someone managed
to stay roughly sane,
like they're good in
my book that's been my,
like basic temperature
guide on this thing,
you didn't have to get everything right,
none of us did,
but if you sort of said roughly sane,
do you sympathize with the
people that really lost it over
the last couple years because
of exactly what you just
explained right there,
there is such a cacophony of nonsense
being spun at all of us all the time,
it's extremely difficult,
and people don't have the time
siphon through all the craziness?
- Yeah, I do understand.
And I have to use the word
check my privilege in a certain way.
My privilege is that I'm a writer,
I get to say what I think all the time.
- But that's not just the privilege,
it's also you do put your neck out there,
I mean, it's not,
- Yeah.
It's a privilege to a degree, but you say,
- Sure.
- No dangerous things or--
- But I mean,
but I say it because I
think that therefore,
so my own attitude is a bit
different to some other people
because I think what is worse
for people is when they see
lies and they just have no outlet for it.
- Yeah.
- They just, I think there
is enormous frustration
brewing everywhere,
we've been through a couple
of really difficult years.
So I do have sympathy with it.
My sympathy for that is not endless
I don't have sympathy for the people,
who've who now believe that absolutely
everything is a conspiracy,
and believe that they've
seen through everything.
- Yeah.
- And all, I've not got
much sympathy with that
because I mean, you,
it's not just that you,
it's not that you have to,
you should find things to trust in,
you can't be completely cynical,
you should find things that you know
to be true and hold on to them.
- Right, if you're the one
guy who knows what's going on,
you probably have an issue.
- I worry there's a lot of that.
- Yeah.
- There's a lot of
autodidacticism really like,
we inevitably we educate
ourselves in areas of a lot,
but I am suspicious of the people
who go from being,
experts on Afghanistan
to experts on vaccines,
to experts on Ukraine, to experts on, I...
- Everyone's an expert
in Ukraine right now.
- They are amazing.
- These people who couldn't
tie their shoes together.
- Yeah.
- And suddenly everyone shows everything.
- About this nation that nobody would--
- Hold my shoes I've gotta go back
to analyzing Afghanistan next week,
if anything kicks off there (laughing).
I think in a way this is because politics
has become a kind of hobby,
it's more than a hobby, a hobby
and then something more for a lot people,
it's carrying an awful lot of weight.
- Yeah.
So we go from like the,
the way it travels and it
jumps across ponds and then odd
things are happening in England.
But what about the way it also shifts?
So we had two years of
everything was about race,
but right now, as we sit here,
everything's about gender.
And we'll talk more
about that in a second,
but that sort of thing, that
it seems to be guided in a
way that that doesn't seem
totally coincidental to me that
the way it actually shifts,
like we're not doing race
that much in America right
this moment, it really does
seem to be more about gender.
Race will come back and then
gender will come back and then
climate will come and.
- Yeah.
- And everything else.
- By the way, I mean, that's sort of way
with climate is another one,
I mean
I listed this recently in a piece
before the Ukraine crisis,
we had the COVID crisis.
And I mean, literally
Dr. Fauci disappeared,
the moment that the
Russian tanks were all--
- It was incredible
they couldn't find him.
- And then before that we had the,
what did we have for the Corona crisis?
Well we had the racist crisis,
we had the Trump crisis,
We had the Brexit crisis,
oh we had the climate crisis.
I like everything cannot be a crisis,
everything cannot be you can't live at
that level of hectoring.
And of all of those,
one of the ones I have
the the least time for
is the other people who shout
about the climate crisis.
There are things that
are important to address,
but when they present it
as they did of the
recent summit in Glasgow,
one minute left to save the planet,
I think you are doing
something pretty wicked
now because you are,
you are making assertions
and whipping people up into
fervours that are not able to be answered.
- I mean, AOC told us
we got 12 years left,
that was about three years ago,
- I mean.
- We're running outta time man.
- Prince Charles said 12 years,
20 years ago so.
- So we're gonna be okay, is
that what you're telling me?
But that is one it's that in some ways,
do you feel like that's the
hardest one to talk about?
I mean look you spent years talking
about Islamism and Gehad,
that was obviously very
hard to talk about,
but we've sort of shifted
off that now that's sort of
shifted, we can talk about race,
we can talk about gender,
but there's something about the
climate one where it's like,
you feel like your whole
career could just go like that,
if you talk about it.
- Could do I mean, it's not
something I do very much on,
but I just note that the,
it seems to be one of the fallback things.
If other crises are not high
and hot enough at the moment we
fall back onto the climate crisis
and again I'm not saying
that there aren't things
to address but just the
way in which this is sold
to the public seems to be
highly deranging, I
mean you're telling kids
that they might not make adulthood,
and that's a terrible thing to do.
And you would only do it
if you're 100% certain,
that was the case.
And they're not.
- Well, they would tell you they are,
but they really--
- If they were,
they would actually be
doing something else.
- Exactly, exactly.
- They'd be like living as
people do when they think the
plane's about to crash.
- Let's shift to China a little bit,
because it seems like everything
in the world is sort of
being driven by China.
And yet I don't sense that we
have as many China experts at
the moment as we have Ukraine
experts, will they shift soon?
- There will be shifting.
- Do you sense they're
making the move to shift.
- Yeah, they'll absolutely be shifting.
- What's the basic way we should frame a
China conversation?
- Well as
I do an interview in this because I say,
what's the rest of the world doing,
whilst we're doing this to ourselves.
'Cause if you go to Beijing
and you look back at us,
and I often find that my books come
from looking back my society
from another place and
somebody said to me recently,
how would you define the West?
And I was like well,
one thing is, you know what
it is when you're not in it,
like when you are in Beijing,
you're not in the West,
if you're in Tokyo,
you're not in the West.
And one of the things I say is like,
if you look at what we
are doing from places
like China or Moscow,
it does look very
strange and you would get
an odd picture of us.
So among other things I said well,
what are the Chinese doing whilst
we're obsessing about social justice?
Or what are the Russians doing whilst
we're obsessing about these things?
And the China thing in
particular is just fascinating
because there's no
scenario in which Russia
would overtake America in
global leadership terms.
It is perfectly possible
within our lifetimes,
we could see China become the
dominant economy in the world,
in fact as Elon Musk and
others have shown you don't,
China only has to sort of
grow at the current rate to
eventually get that.
And I think this is one of
the things we should just be
thinking about is some of the
context we have to have in our
minds is, let's say
even if we in America, we in Britain,
we in the West, managed to
make every single field of
expertise exactly
dominated in America by well,
representing America,
with 13% Black people,
you know 50% or just over 50% of women,
no point whatever percent of trans people,
even if we did all of that,
does America beat China?
Now that was--
- Even if we did all
of those lofty things.
- That would strike me as being
a really important question to sort out,
and I can't find people in America enough,
people willing to think about it,
but that would be the underlying
thing is whilst we were
doing all of these strange
things for our past
and our present, the
only global competitor,
which has no problem with
racism is currently operating
concentration camps.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I cite some, I mean, just terrifically,
awful racist things that modern China
and the founders of modern
China have said and done.
And again,
I don't think one in a
million Americans knows this.
I don't think one in a million
British people knows it.
And I just this is the
context we need to operate in.
- Do we have any of the defenses
to stop the encroachment of China
or stop that they will be the superpower
and you know even just in,
in the last couple days, Joe Biden said,
there's new world order coming,
and something to the effect of,
maybe we'll be in charge of it.
- I've said for many years
if you didn't like the era of
so called American hegemony,
you're gonna love the China's era.
I have a human rights complaint,
you'll tell the CCP.
- Yeah, they'll love that.
- How interesting.
- Yeah.
- How interesting that--
- They've special rooms for people like us
I'd assume.
- Please step this way,
- Its a--
- I mean it's really it
feel horribly late empire,
what we're doing.
- So how do we reverse course on this?
Or let's say there was,
if you were advising
Biden or there was a new
administration, I know it's
not just a political answer,
I know that.
But if you were guiding some
sort of philosophy that was
gonna push back on some of
this what would be the--
- Well, one thing is you've
gotta stop elite capture,
which has definitely happened
in all of our countries.
I'll list some of the
examples of it really worrying
high profile examples in
Britain, America, Australia,
New Zealand, Canada,
where people in our political elites
have been bought up by China.
And maybe in the future,
we will treat those people
as we are currently treating
Russian oligarchs, finally,
who looted their country and
then moved to the West and
spent their all gotten games.
Maybe there will come a time
when we actually treat the
people who,
who helped China arrive at
this point from the West with
that kind of retribution.
But that would be a start.
It would also be a start to address
how business is gonna address this,
'Cause as we know constantly,
businesses that have been
born in countries like
America and have free market principles,
completely adapt those principles
in all of the dominated
the Chinese market.
Should Americans and others
in the West have an attitude
towards this in the products
we buy in the products we
engage with I think so.
- Well, it's funny now
you hear Biden saying, oh,
we should buy more American or
we should make more American.
- Right.
- Things here, it sort of
sounds like something that,
that orange guy was kind
of saying for a while.
- It was a sort of thing,
which only a few years back
you would've definitely been
accused of jingoism.
- Yeah of course.
- Of course.
- Right.
- I mean all of us,
I mean from the Corona era
as well have had this sort of
supply chain issue suddenly
come back like turns out energy,
independence is quite useful,
quite useful to be able
to not rely on China,
for all sorts of things
from medical products all the way through
to energy, same with Russia.
- You know that the two COVID tests
remember Biden sent two COVID tests to
every American during
the state of the union.
- Yeah.
- You know that they're made in China,
- Made in China.
- I have two of them.
- I know it seems to be some unbelievably
dark grand joke.
- It's like if a fiction writer
- Oh yeah.
- Was writing it, you'd be like,
it's too on point.
- No, come on, yeah you see that,
- Yeah.
- Novel, but then don't,
- Don't stretch our credility.
- Is there anything else we can do,
I guess know a little more
or is it really also that it's
just like when the average person maybe
is thinking about China's encroaching
on the West and our hegemony
and all of it's gonna collapse and,
and you'll realize how good you had it,
but it's too late,
it's like that isn't as
emotionally abrasive as just like,
oh, let's tear down a
statue or America's racist,
something like that.
- Yeah.
- It's so much to think about
truly that this country,
all the world away could
really be trying to upend
the world that we just
totally take for granted.
- I think the most important thing
is that we get ourselves into context.
I mean, historically we'll come onto that,
but I mean historically
but also in the present.
I mean, again,
if people in America leave
America and go to certain places
in the world, like China
far east, middle east,
you'll see that
questions you tear
yourselves up over here,
for right or wrong,
do not bother or detain these societies.
And that should be solitary.
You know.
- You go into reparations
- Yeah.
- In a portion of this that's
you described yourself as
privileged because you're an author, but
there will be a cost for
talking about reparations,
my friend.
- Well, I do reparations
after the history chapter.
- Yeah.
- Where I describe how--
- Yeah, we've been sort of balancing.
- The war on on history,
the war in our history,
in the West is just,
it just has to stop,
has to be put into a proper context,
I'm all for the debate by the way.
I mean there's obviously
a sort of a debate
on empire going on again,
a new debate on slavery,
but all of it is as if we
haven't had these debates before,
as if we've never thought
about them before.
And, and so yes,
one of the questions
that's now coming up again
is reparations.
Britain by the way paid
significant reparations
when the slave trade ended.
In fact, there's evidence,
I analyze explain it in the
book that Britain actually paid
more to abolish the slave trade
than ever gained through the slave trade.
That of course 'cause Britain,
after we abolished the slave trade,
also policed the abolition
of the slave trade across the
high seas in the 19th century,
thousands of British sailors
lost their lives in those
operations, stopping the
Brazilians, for instance,
who continued their slave
trade into the 1880s,
stopping the Brazilians and
others from trafficking people
across the globe,
but also Britain paid the
money in fatefully reparations,
those who'd lost money they
all British people paid
a cost throughout the 19th century
in an upsurge of pricing of goods,
because if you got rid of
buying goods from places
that were producing them from slavery,
then of course you were paying more.
So there's a lot of evidence,
that Britain as were already paid down,
it's gained from the slave trade.
Well again, not one in a
million people knows that.
- Yeah.
- And so now when people say
you need to pay reparations for
what you did in 18th century,
I think, well that's interesting,
same thing in this country,
in the United States, people talk as if,
this country didn't fight a damn civil war
over the issue.
And I think a number of times in the book,
I use a couple of fantastic quotes of,
Nietzsche from on the
"Genealogy of Morals."
And one of his analogies,
which I lift is he talks of people who,
pick at long closed wounds
and pick off the scabs and
then scream about how
much they've been hurt.
This is horribly pertinent.
I think that's what we're dealing with,
we're dealing with people today
who are demanding money,
for things they didn't suffer.
And demanding money from people
who did no wrong.
And it's got so much worse
in this latest iteration,
previous attempts or claims for,
for reparations were different,
but by the time you get into
the current decade and Ta-Nehisi Coates
basically starts off this latest round
with a peace in the Atlantic,
but by the time of the
last Democrat primaries,
all the Democrats were
talking about reparations,
seriously talking about
how to do reparations.
One of the first things that
Joe Biden did when he got
office was to launch an
investigation to whether,
you know whether and how this country
could get into this question.
- Even though Barack Obama
virtually never talked about it
just four years before.
- Right.
- And was black and put it to bed--
- Because--
- Was not called a sell
out because of it or--
- Because this a new generation
has been persuaded to open a wound,
they didn't suffer from
and scream about how
much they've suffered.
And you know there's actually,
this is why I do this sub
chapter on reparations
is that there's a deep
moral question within this,
which is at this stage,
it's people who look like people
to whom wrong things
were done in the past,
demanding money from people
who look like people who could
have done the wrong things.
If you wanna get further
into it, you have to say,
you have to basically
do a genetic database
of the American population.
What do you do by, I mean,
this is one of the many moral
problems is I don't believe
that anyone living has
the right to be forgiven
and no one living has
the right to forgive.
They don't have the right,
and I explain why in the book
that simply in Maltum
you do not have the right
to apologize for something you did not do,
and nobody else has the right
to accept an apology if the
wrong was not done to them.
So we are in this set of
demands that are being made,
which I'm afraid must be dismissed
carefully, sensitively at times
and insensitively at others.
But it's not going to work,
and this idea has to be put
to bed because we are now
dealing with historic retribution,
not just reparations,
but historic retribution.
- Do you think that it's also
designed to intentionally
inflame racial tensions?
- Oh yeah, of course.
- So if you said to a second generation,
Mexican immigrant, legal Mexican immigrant
in the United States who busted their butt
came here, now
they are a parent now and
now they have young kids and
they had nothing to do with slavery,
came here, don't have that much,
but are working hard
for the American dream.
Or if you took my family
that I'm fourth generation
American, but
Holocaust survivors on both
sides of my family all came here
with nothing that had nothing
to do with slavery that you
would and then suddenly
you were saying to people,
but you have to give money to this thing,
even we don't know whose
ancestors act like really,
are we gonna really be able
to track this correctly?
That you're gonna end up
causing people to be racist?
- Of course.
- I mean--
- Of course you would,
of course you would.
And it's dire everywhere you look at it.
I mean, here's another one.
What do you do with the Black people
descended from Black people who sold
their brothers and sisters?
Do they pay out?
I mean, Voltaire said this centuries ago,
Voltaire said,
"The only thing even worse than
"what the Europeans were doing in,
"selling Black Africans
and trading them across the Atlantic
were the Africans who sold their brothers.
Are we gonna to go to Africa
and find the people who
descended from the people who did that?
I mean some of the few
memoirs of slaves we have,
like Equiano describe how their neighbors
in enabling village in Africa just came
and stole them in the night.
Is there any reparation for that?
- Are we gonna give reparations
to the millions of Black
people who probably don't want it?
Or the immigrants from
Senegal who have thrived
or several other countries,
Caribbean countries who'd
come here and thrive?
- It's so obviously not
possible that it's purely
designed to open a wound
and to claim superiority
for yourself.
- Do you think it's also
intentionally counter to the way
humans operate?
Meaning that let's say,
we had this grand program of reparations
and let's say all the
experts got together,
and Ta-Nehisi Coates and all of the,
everyone on MSNBC got
their panel of experts--
- And all the people who
aren't willing to send,
who aren't willing to show
their voter ID at the booth are
willing to hand over their DNA.
- That's another good one, right?
Because you don't have
to show your ID to vote
but somehow, you're gonna
have to show some sort of ID
for larry to this but okay fine.
But let's say we get the
great panel of all time.
They get every socialist
and communist on there
and race expert on there,
and they come up with the number.
They come up with a number
that each black person
in America should get and let's just come,
let's come up with an insane
$250,000 per person right?
It's insane we're gonna
figure out how to fund it,
I know we have no money,
but let's say they do the
exact perfect thing that they
purport to want to do.
Do you think they also don't
fundamentally understand just
human nature,
which is that the progressives
of 20 years from now will say,
look what our--
- Sure.
- The anti-progressives before us did,
they sold us out.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- For 250 grand--
- And of course--
- And it won't solve anything,
- No
- Is the other part, right?
- And a generation on there
will be new people saying
that wasn't enough.
There's a very funny skit,
you've probably seen Dave Chappelle do on,
"what would happen if."
- Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Which are brands to get shares in before
that money was dolled out,
it's a non start it's
designed to be divisive.
And here's one of the
problems that comes from that,
which is that it's so demeaning
of our history in the West.
It's so demeaning,
racism and colonialism
and slavery were part
of the story of the West as they have been
the part of the story of all
societies throughout human
history and in many societies today,
but they are not the history of the West.
They are part of the history.
They are not the history of the West.
And that has been totally
misrepresented in our day.
As if these sins were the
only thing that defined us,
well actually what defined
the West was that these were
things we recognized to be sins.
Modern China doesn't recognize that,
and many other nations and
countries and societies around
the world, don't recognize that.
- Speaking of the history
let's shift to religion,
this is one as
I've definitely come around on,
the belief side,
at least very different than where I was
say five or six years ago.
I think you need something
behind just the liberalism
that we love to keep this ship going.
Talk to me a little bit about religion,
would you Douglas Murray?
- Well, I explained that you basically,
you can't take down the West,
unless you take down the
religious element of it
specifically the
Judeo-Christian tradition,
what's worrying at the moment
is that there is a
simultaneous assault on the two
traditions of the West both
the philosophical tradition,
including the secular tradition
and the religious tradition.
So the Western churches, they
go into remorseless detail,
even the Catholic church,
Judaism what's that thing--
- They've gone woke, they've gone woke.
- They've decided the point
of Judaism or the Catholicism,
is social justice,
and say as much church
of England Episcopalians,
all these people have decided
that they're gonna do,
they're basically they're
gonna give up gods
and they're gonna go for woke.
And that's not very
survivable actually I think
'cause it just turns the
things that are meant to be
the most profound sources of
meaning on your society into
just another banal,
repetition of the banal
things that you get everywhere
from an art gallery to
cable news to everywhere else,
It's just you also get it
at church or a synagogue,
and so that, I'm not devastating moment,
but what makes it even more devastating
is that this is happening simultaneously
with an attack on the secular
philosophical traditions
of the West.
The tradition of Athens, the
tradition of the enlightenment.
I mean, in the last few years,
every philosopher in enlightenment,
everyone has been brought
down by this crowd
of anti-Westerners, anti-Westerners.
They've done for Voltaire whose actually,
whose statues disappeared in Paris.
They've come for David Hume,
for John Stuart Mill, for everyone.
And again,
I say that's because that's
with the history thing,
that's what you have to do,
if you want to destroy the West.
In the same way that if you
wanna take down America,
you have to take down
the roots of America.
You have to take down its heroes.
You have to take down Lincoln,
you gotta take down
Jefferson, you gotta take,
take down the gods of the Republic.
If in Britain you've gotta
take down Winston Churchill,
that's why they go for him so bad.
It's in the same way,
if you want to destroy
the tradition of reason
in the West,
you go for the figures who gave
us the tradition of reason.
And everybody from Aristotle
who the Washington posts a
couple years ago described us
the grandfather of scientific
racism who among other
things stood accused
of being named by Charles Murray as his,
- Yeah.
- Favorite philosopher.
So two found and this particular writer
in the Washington post was disturbed
to find Aristotle writing 2,300 years ago.
Did not agree with everything
that Washington Post says in
2020 as a shocking discovery,
unbelievable realization,
what are you gonna do with these idiots,
Aristotle, God.
What did he know?
And it's the same with the
philosophers and enlightenment.
I mean,
you could say that one of the
reasons why the philosophy
enlightenment have been so
attacked in recent years is
because they were living in
the time of the two original
sins slavery and empire,
and they stand accused now of
not having spent enough time
thinking about the same things
that Ibram X. Kendi pretends
to think about or Robin DiAngelo.
Well, you know David Hume was trying to,
work out how we got ourselves out of
a period of basically superstition writers
like Voltaire were trying to
separate out the church and the state.
These are quite important
tasks and important roles.
Should they have dedicated
themselves to other things that
we now call social justice?
Possibly, but they were
busy with other things.
- Probably not.
- They were busy with other things.
And again, there's just this
unbelievable presumption
about this,
and I say, I mean, I'm very keen to play
the game back at them like David Hume,
is attacked now because of
one footnote in one of his
essays which is known
by all human scholars,
and is racist, a racist statement.
He's attacked for this one, footnote.
Kendi and others sold him for it.
I think that's probably
the only passage of Hume,
Kendi has ever read,
but okay, let's do this,
with other people,
- Yeah. -
- Why, who might fall if you did this,
if you said something racist once
trick who else might fall?
but here's one Karl Marx,
I go through in considerable detail,
Karl Marx's letters and his
essays are filled with racism,
packed with it, he uses the
"N" word all over the place,
he usually hyphenated with Jew,
not used in a very flattering
light itself either.
I mean, Marx was a horribly
racist antisemitic,
a really very bigoted figure
who by our own modern standards should
not be regarded as survivable.
Nobody's done the task on him,
a new statue went up to angles
only a couple years ago,
and new statue of Marx went up,
- Yeah.
- Just a couple years ago.
So why is it only
happened to these people?
I think here in questions like that,
you see the sources of what
I'm trying to get at here,
which is that the war on the West,
is a war on all of the things we treasure.
designed to leave behind only people
who very militant political activists
want to leave standing as the only people
with an explanation for our society.
- So this is sort of the same
question that I asked you
at the beginning in terms ,
of why didn't our institutions
have enough to stand up,
our secular institutions,
but are you surprised that
the religious institutions,
whether you fully believe in
them or not that they didn't
have better defenses,
you would think that these
things that have really lasted
for thousands of years and have
made mistakes along the way,
and wars have been fought and
we can do that whole thing,
but that every you're not exaggerating,
when you talk about what's
happening in the churches
and the templates of
America right now I mean,
they've traded in most of
what we thought thought their
beliefs were, many of
them not all of them--
- And it's very strange
because I mean, it's,
I agree with the
historian of Christianity,
histor of ancient world, Tom Holland,
who has said in the past,
that actually Christianity, for instance,
it should do the weird stuff.
Like what makes Christianity extraordinary
are the claims it makes about the world,
if the weird stuff as
Tom Holland calls it,
you know include,
the Virgin birth, the
crucifixion, the resurrection,
but this is Christianity, take them away.
And you haven't got Christianity,
insert in its place the same as I say,
banal things that you get everywhere else
in the age and you don't
really have a religion,
you just got another iteration
of the social justice
movement but I believe,
that weird stuff is
absolutely central to it.
Same thing with Judaism.
It's the things that make them different
from everything else,
sort of the things that
you'd want to hold onto,
not the stuff you'd give up.
- No.
- And import this like crappy DiAngeloism.
why would you go from angels to DiAngelo?
- That's a good question, I should have a,
I consider that as Prager
my Rabbi I'll have him,
I'll have him ask that next
time at the high holidays.
Well from there actually,
that's a good segway,
to gratitude which is next in the book.
Man, we could all use a little
bit more of that in the West.
Huh?
- Yeah.
- I think some people are
kind of waking up to it now,
do you sense that?
- Absolutely.
- There is a feeling of, oh man,
we might be really giving this thing away.
- Maybe things like
Ukraine, remind us of that.
you've got
people in 2022 homes are
being shelled by tanks
in the invading neighboring country
and it could be us,
maybe it helps a little
bit to put in proportion,
the luck we have in basically stable
and vaguely peaceful societies
or broadly peaceful seriously ,
substantially peaceful,
mainly peaceful societies.
The reason why I write about gratitude
is because apart of it has
been much of my mind in recent years,
it's as I say, it's the
only counter you can
have to resentment.
And we've lived in an age of resentment
and the war on the West,
significantly, a war
waged by resentful people,
people who wallow in resentment,
who wallow in blaming other
people for anything in their
lives that does not go right.
Who always have someone to blame.
Nietzsche again, writes about this,
the problem with resentment,
the problem with resentful people is that
there is actually only one
true answer you can have to
them to stop their resentment,
which is to say to them, you are right.
There is something which
is wrecking your life,
and is ruining you.
The thing is you, you are the thing.
Now, the problem with that
is that the last message
anyone wants to hear.
And so there will always be an
inbuilt reason for resentful
people to stop ever looking inwards.
- Is that the greatest
trick of social justice
in a way that it took
every thing off the self,
it took everything off the individual
and just put it on the machine?
- It's certainly one of them.
And you have to talk to
these things in similar,
at similar depths.
And by the way,
I think this is something right's
got very badly wrong in recent years,
the left talks in terms of
resentment and the right will
talk about tax cuts.
that's not actually
talking on the same level.
- Yeah.
- They're talking at a tectonic level
and the right is talking
at a fidling level important fiddling,
no doubt, but fidling.
The only counter to real
resentment is gratitude
is to turn your attitude
towards life around
and being encouraged to do so,
now this is perfectly possible but,
and one of the things is
to realize what a life of
resentment actually looks like.
Dostoevsky, "The brothers Karamazov."
Has a fantastic passage
where the devil appears
and says to one of the brothers,
the one the brother
he says to one of the brothers
that gratitude something he can't do.
And when I read that first,
I thought that is amazing.
Only Dostoevsky would throw away
that insight that the devil.
- Yeah.
- Is not capable of gratitude,
but gratitude comes or
should come from, okay,
these are things that are,
I mean, if somebody says,
for instance, well,
what have you produced in the West
other than slavery and
racism and inequality
and all of these things I say,
okay, let me just start with cities,
Paris, Rome, Florence, Barcelona, Madrid,
Lisbon, Venice.
- Portland used to be pretty nice--
- I wouldn't list Portland.
(laughs)
- The point is--
- In the old days.
- The city, the list could
go on almost endlessly.
The great university cities,
Heidelberg, Regensburg,
Oxford, Cambridge,
you think this is nothing?
I'm just talking their cities here,
I've not even got on the rest of it.
Have not got on to
scientific achievements,
I've not got on to all
the cultural achievements,
but I could,
now if you look at it in that light,
be reminded that yes,
it's possible to do what
the deconstruction is,
argued that we should all do,
which is to tear everything apart,
break everything down,
always deconstruct everything
other than their own careers.
You can do that.
Or you can stand back and
look at what you have.
I mean you could,
look at a block of marble
and talk about the labor
that it costs to get it out of the ground.
You could talk about the cost of labor
and whether or not
people were properly paid
for getting it out of the ground,
or you could stand back
and look at the Pieter,
you know these are two
totally different attitudes,
but they're both possible.
You can stand in Venice
and say what a terrible
testimony to inequality
or you could Marvel.
- Yeah.
- And there's one that's
better than the other.
I think that's what you're saying.
- You get what I'm leading to.
- I think I got it.
I think I got it.
Culture is what you end on,
and we've sort of this whole
conversation in some ways
couched around culture,
but everyone says we're in
a culture war right now.
Or the culture wars are raging.
- Yes, the cultural one is
the most painful one in a way,
because this is where the
DiAngeloisim, Kendism,
this is where it is really,
it is ugliest is when this
horrible retributive game
looking at everything
through eyes of slavery and
colonialism gets put
onto this horrible beam
gets put onto the most delicate, fragile
and precious things.
I give examples of artwork
that has actually been closed up now,
including all of my favorite painters.
His work's been shut away in
the Tate gallery in London
because of a claim that one
of the figures in it is racist.
And the man who painted this Rex Whistler
died on his first day in
action in 1944 in Normandy.
He's posthumously been defamed by
the Tate gallery as a racist.
He wasn't a racist and he lost
his life fighting Narcism.
And they've defamed him posthumously,
they've done the same thing
with artists after artists.
They're doing the same
thing with classical music
at the moment.
They can't find enough
black Barack composers.
- Yeah.
- So what,
- So what, but there are Barack ensembles
across America that now
tearing themselves apart over this,
orchestras doing the same thing.
- Yeah.
- They notice that,
I mean that the cannon of
Western music and Western
literature is horribly dominated by,
by what they call dead white males.
By the way, one of the things
I love in that is that they,
they don't only attack people
for being white and being
males, but for being dead,
it's like what kinda a loser would die.
- The least they could do is
stick around so we can attack
them to their face you know.
- What kinda losers are these people?
Like bagh!
So these dead white males and
now are sailed for absolutely
everything and as a result,
they've these Anti-Western
activists have reduced the arts
to the same again,
but now retributive
aggressive resentful game,
as everything else they've
even done a on gardening.
One of my favorite
passages in this book is,
is the passage racist gardening.
When I was doing the audio book,
I had trouble with this bit,
'cause I was just laughing so much
I had to do so many takes because it's,
he's just preposterous,
there's even a guy in Canada
who made waves a couple years ago
who said that, Lawns of racist,
- Oh yes.
- The whole of the perfect
lawn is a racist construct.
And the--
- Lawn mower is the slave
master, something like that
- I mean his analogy--
- Doesn't mean worker.
- His analogy doesn't
stand up to much attention,
but they've done this to everything.
- Yeah.
- And this causes in me a
certain resentment of itself,
because I think that it's,
one of the coolest things
you could do to the gifts
we've been given.
They've done it on Shakespeare,
the globe theater in London
now has a set of seminars on
decolonizing Shakespeare.
They found that some of his
characters aren't right.
- You can't believe it.
- They weren't all perfect,
Shakespeare's characters,
one Shakespeare star in America said,
"This language of
lighted darkness, I mean,
"This language is all over the place."
Saying, well, took a quite recently,
people used to think that Shakespeare
was quite good with language.
- There was--
- Better than your
average American academic,
for Sure.
- Wait, till they find
out about George Lucas,
he wrote a little saying
about the light in the dark.
you know.
- It's all looked at in the same light
as we are better than all of these people.
Like you think you stand
here to judge Shakespeare?
You really think you have that right?
So as I said the culture
bit is the most painful
in a way because it's the same story
as the war on White people.
It's the same story as
the war on our history,
the war on our religious inheritance
and our philosophical inheritance.
This is the war on our
cultural inheritance.
And it's all done in the same way
with the same anger and resentment.
And I try to explain at the end,
how I think we get out of that.
- You don't have to give away the ending,
but give me an ice ending for this,
and then I want to continue
with one other topic
that we're gonna,
we'll do like two or three
minutes of it for the public.
And then I wanna shift the
rest of it to the locals
community regarding something else--
- Sure.
- That you and I have been talking
about somewhat publicly and privately.
But give me a classic Douglas
Murray adding to an interview
as only Douglas Murray can do.
- God, that put some pressure on me.
No, well here's what I think.
I think we've been being polite
and I'm done with it,
totally done with it.
All of what I describe in this
book is only going on because
of we happen to live in
highly tolerant societies.
So I give a set of what it would look like
if we stopped being tolerant.
I mean here a couple of
standoffs, I would do.
I feel this very strongly,
if you don't respect my ancestors,
I see no reason to respect yours.
if you don't show any
respect for my history,
I don't see why I should
pretend to respect yours.
If you don't respect my culture,
I don't need to respect yours.
If you don't respect me,
I see no reason to respect you.
Now what does this look like?
This lack of politeness?
Well, it would look
like telling some truths
that are a rare as being too polite,
not to say or to in
recent years at any rate,
in the end of his series on civilization,
Lord Clark memorably said that
courtesy was one of the
things that defined the West,
its a very interesting thing to fall
on at the end of this thing,
but courtesy is a hugely important thing
in Western society, but it's not endless.
So here would be an, a non
courteous thing to say.
We've been told that other ways of knowing
other ways of doing maths, non race,
anti-racist science
all this sort of thing.
Yet we do not go to any Aboriginal
communities for vaccines.
We go to no first peoples
for cancer treatment.
We go to them for no
mathematical scientific
or artistic discoveries.
We do not go to them to
rediscover other languages
and other cultures,
partly largely because
such communities seem to
have had not much interest
in other cultures,
unlike the Western mind,
they seem not to have
taken a great interest.
So the not courteous
thing would be us saying
we've been courteous for an
awfully long time and we're
gonna stop because it seems
not to be doing us much good.
So we will pursue truth wherever
we want to pursue it for
whatever means we have and
whatever disciplines we have.
And we will stop pretending
that alongside all the great
philosophy of the West native
American philosophy is equal.
I mean, I have a bit in the book
where Lampoon these American
authors who you just know
at the end of everything
are going to find a sort of tribal leader
who says something totally banal,
and claim that it's...
- Yeah.
- Amazingly profound.
- But like I'm willing to
pretend that for a bit,
not really willing to pretend
that we can get rid of
Aristotle and Plato and Voltaire
and a everyone else and keep
only boring tribal leader banality.
So yeah, the end process would
be not playing nice anymore.
And as it happens,
I don't think it would be a
very nice solution in itself.
But I do fire it as a warning shot.
Like don't push us there.
It is I mean it is a totally mad thing
to do within the West
and I should stress out,
this is about Western Anti-Westernism.
There are other types of Anti-Westernism
- Yeah.
- Around the world,
but this is about Western Anti-Westernism.
And it is a very strange thing
to try to persuade majority
communities in societies to
believe that they are evil and
impossible ever to atone for that evil.
Di Angelou says, "White people
cannot get out of whiteness
"and there is no good whiteness."
No, to hell with these
people to hell with them,
for pretending that a white
child born and brought up in the
21st century in America has
to be deemed as having no good
things to access through their life.
These people have to be
cleared outta the way,
and I'm trying to do my small amount
to make sure that happens.
- Douglas Murray, you've
still got it my friend,
(laughing) you still got it.
And I will have you on
for a 10th appearance,
if you will join me again.
But, so this is the end
of the proper interview,
but now I wanna do something a
little bit different just for
a couple minutes and we'll
leave some of this on YouTube
publicly, but then I wanna
take the rest to locals,
'cause I think it's interesting.
We did a panel at NatCan,
where they were trying to piece together,
it was me, you Yoram
Hazony and Sohrab Amari,
and we were trying to piece together
what a new right could look like.
And sort of where the
minorities fit within that,
if a society is to have any sort of
traditional conservative values.
And it was a pretty damn good conversation
if I do say so myself
and there were a couple
hundred people there for it,
you know that David and I made
this announcement in the last
couple weeks about having kids
and we're obviously
overjoyed and it's great.
And 99% of what I got,
especially from my friends
on the conservative side of the aisle
was amazing, well nothing
but love and support.
A lot of it publicly,
plenty of it privately,
but it was, it was all good,
but there was this mostly
anonymous frog related,
but not all,
some more religious people
anger towards this related
to gay, related to IVF, a
whole bunch of other things.
And I thought,
I don't wanna pay too much attention
to what a small minority are saying,
but it's not nothing.
And I often say to you,
at some point in all of our interviews,
you so happen to be gay zippity dude.
Okay, here we are.
But as a conservative or a,
I don't all the words,
I don't wanna put anything in your mouth.
What do we do with this tension?
What do you think we do with this tension?
- I discover from the NatCan conference
that the conservative
there think I'm liberal.
- Right? Well, so that's why, I mean it
it's like you are a liberal
in the right sense of liberalism, right ?
Like--
- No, they think I'm a
liberal, in all senses.
- But they think the, right.
So they think, well they
think even the right,
the right sense of liberalism liberals
are in the wrong sense of liberalism.
So yes, I'm with you on that right?
So they, you know.
- They've got an alarming
discovery of that panel.
- Right, in some ways you were
the most liberal person on the panel,
- Oh.
- In a certain way.
- It's an interesting
position for me to be in
- Which is odd right?
So you're thought of as
a British conservative,
but from an American context,
you were thought of as a liberal,
but we had this debate,
how can conservatism come to grips,
grasping some of the things
that you write about religion
and family and that there's a,
an inheritance over
generations and all of,
all of the stuff, all of the stuff.
And I don't want to, it's funny,
I haven't talked about
it publicly that much,
'cause I don't wanna give
too much credence to it,
'cause it was a very small
minority of angry people.
It wasn't, and by the way,
not just angry people,
'cause some of the things I
think are legitimate concerns.
If two gay men have kids,
well, where's the role of the mother.
- Right.
- Things like that, there are things I've.
- I've written about that.
- Yeah.
There are things to talk about,
so what do you think
we do with all of this?
- Well one realization I have
had since been in America
is that I mean,
there are uglier things I wouldn't share
that I knew before on the right.
- Oh.
- I think that is true,
- So I'm trying to nip
this one in the butt,
how about that?
- Yeah, I think there are
uglier things on the right.
I think there are uglier
things on the right
like there are on the left everywhere.
I think maybe part of the
right got a bit complacent in
recent years about this,
we were so used to leftist overreach,
Jordan and I talked quite a
lot clearly publicly about,
where the left goes wrong.
And we did so partly in
the assumption that, well,
everyone knows where the right goes wrong.
But I think that the right in
America in particular might be
relearning that lesson at the moment.
Maybe it's a never ending lesson.
I mean, there are people I've
had a couple of totally minor
confrontations myself since
being here with sort of ugly
troll like figures,
but slightly closer to the
mainstream on the right
than I'd be comfortable with them being
who play with antisemitism, for instance,
play with other bigotries.
I think they're sort of
edge Lords of the right,
who are basically doing
the same reprehensible game
that parts of the left do that compares ,
on the left
play with Che Guevara and
these guys play with panache,
you know and--
- So what if we remove
the troll part of it
or the edge Lord part of it,
or just like the internet part
of it, but what let's say,
what do you think about just
the people that maybe have a
purely really religious perspective?
- Well the strange thing
in this country again,
it's something I've discovered since,
living here is that I mean,
you have something in America
which really doesn't exist in Britain,
which is, I mean, you have, I mean,
so-called integralists for instance,
I honestly, I didn't take
these people seriously,
I honestly thought they must be kidding,
but you want to introduce, for instance,
Catholic social doctrines,
the foundation for ethics in America.
- That was part of the conversation
that we had in NatCan.
- But I mean,
but like Catholics aren't even nearly
a majority in America.
- Right.
- There's no way that
a minority can assert
its moral principles over a majority
in a secular Republic.
I mean, no way.
- Have to kill an awful lot of people--
- And in any case,
the history of Europe and the
16th century ought to be some
in 17th century ought to be
some small reminder of why,
I mean literally,
this is why I couldn't believe
that the integralists were serious,
but I thought you don't
know how Europe went down
on this very issue and how long it took
significant thinkers
and brilliant figures to untangle this?
Why would you be trying
to retangle that again.
(upbeat music)
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here,
and to get notified of
all of future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.